is it weird to you to not be looking at
the camera this whole interview I
constantly have been turning towards the
camera like I'm talking to him yes it's
it's a habit uh because my whole life
I've just been talking to a camera who
are you thinking about when you're
looking at the camera do you like
imagine somebody I'm fully thinking
about the person just sitting watching
it and I almost it's weird when I'm
looking at the camera I don't see a
camera I'm like in a haze picturing what
the viewer is seeing when they watch it
yeah that makes sense and that's where
I'll be saying things and or doing
something and then like when I'm
watching I'm like that's not what I want
and then I'll freeze up it's very weird
when I'm filming and then for people who
haven't worked with me too much they'll
think like I don't know it's very weird
like how I go about it because I'll just
be doing whatever like lighting a
firework all right this is a thousand
dollar if I were gonna go to line of it
and I'll like freeze because in my head
I'm like this I don't know I don't like
how that float or how that shot looked
because I it's weird I can perfectly
picture what I'm filming by just looking
at the camera and then putting myself
through the lens of the camera while
making content and I can do it at the
same time so you're like real-time
editing in my video yeah that's
something that didn't at the start come
natural to me but in the last probably
like five years it's happened and so I
would say it's one of my greatest
strengths but I don't know how I
developed it but anytime I'm filming
anything like it's almost like the like
right side of my brain I just can just
look at it I see exactly what I'm
filming and I can just picture it well
it's probably do recording the video
being the talent for the video and then
watching the editing and like analyzing
you carefully do that over and over
again over you ten thousand times yeah
you do the editing more than the being
in front of the camera so like you
you start to see yourself from that
third person perspective exactly then
maybe that actually helps with the
nerves of it too like you see it as
creating a video versus performing uh
right yeah yeah I think so you know I
it's weird I've never
been nervous talking to a camera it's
it's harder for me to talk to a person
that doesn't talk to a camera which I
feel like a lot of people say that
though that are whatever make content
right interesting I've heard that so
many times
or maybe not maybe I'm just awkward
enough maybe they're practiced I to me
it's I mean both are terrifying but
being in front of the camera about
yourself is so much easier really yeah
so much easier I preferred a million
times over
[Applause]
but that's my whole life you know so
it's just that's why it's interesting
like you've spent more of your time
talking to people yeah it comes natural
and I talked to a
piece of plastic oh yeah I guess you're
talking to a person too they're just
saying on the other side of the camera
yeah there's just a pixel on the screen